you
[Music]
good morning thank you for your prompt
return from the coffee break I know that
can be that can be tricky and welcome to
our session this morning where we're
going to be talking about artificial
intelligence for accessibility so the
way we're going to organize this session
is after some brief introductory remarks
each of our three panelists will be
giving a short presentation to set the
stage about their research in specific
application areas of AI for
accessibility and then we'll actually be
doing a panel style Q&A so we have some
starting questions to kick off
discussion but we really want to make
this an interactive session with the
audience so please as you're hearing the
presentations make some notes about
questions you'd like to ask the
panelists and we're going to be sure
that more than half the time in the
session is for for dialogue back and
forth so just a background you know why
is it important to think about
accessibility as a topic domain for the
application and motivation of AI
research worldwide more than 1 billion
people identify as disabled in some way
according to the most recent World
Health Organization statistics just
within the United States alone recent
census data indicates that one in five
adults has some kind of a disability and
of course besides permanent disability
there are a whole spectrum of ranges of
special needs to consider so for example
people might become temporarily disabled
perhaps with a broken limb or even
situationally disabled perhaps if you're
driving your car then you're not able to
use your visual attention or if you are
pushing a shopping cart or stroller
you're not able to use your limbs so
when we think about disability in this
more temporary and situational sense the
range of people who can be helped when
we think about accessibility
applications becomes even broader this
is a priority for Microsoft as a company
so our CEO Satya Nadella shown here in
this really cool cutout head
in it as an email so the company a few
months ago one of the things he said was
as I think about living our mission top
of mind for me is how we must make
Microsoft products accessible to the
more than 1 billion people globally of
all abilities Universal Design is
central to how we realize our mission
and I will continue to devote my passion
to this priority and I think that
thinking about how advances in
artificial intelligence can help not
only Microsoft but the entire technology
community move forward on addressing
some of these very impactful challenges
is a really exciting and timely topic to
consider our chief accessibility officer
Jenny Leigh flurry puts together this
slide that I wanted to share with you
because I think it helps give an
overview not complete but a good
overview of some of the key topic areas
in accessibility that we can begin to
think about as challenge areas to
address with AI technologies so for
example from from Microsoft's
perspective company-wide we think about
six main categories of disability that
our technologies are trying to address
and those include visual disabilities
hearing disabilities cognitive
disabilities which i think is a really
interesting one that doesn't always
necessarily come readily to mind but is
a really large and growing segment that
people are becoming aware of speech and
communication disabilities motor and
mobility impairments and then this last
category I know Jenny struggles to come
up with a good name for it and again
this is a topic that's just beginning I
think to come to many people's awareness
she's disturbed neural and she's trying
to refer here to conditions such as
post-traumatic stress disorder anxiety
depression and thinking about those
conditions as well and how technology
can help people to better manage and
deal with those types of situations and
of course this is a somewhat simplified
taxonomy of disability so of course many
people might have
of things from conditions from across
several of these different categories
certain kinds of illnesses or medical
conditions might result in different
combinations of disabilities so for
example people with ALS such as Stephen
Hawking have a condition that causes
motor disability but then because of the
impact of that motor disability that
also impacts their ability to produce
speech so you would have a combination
of motor and speech needs and all of
these I think are really rich areas for
thinking about the application of AI and
so our panelists today we're lucky to
have with us are all internationally
known experts in accessibility research
and have all begun to use both automatic
and human in the loop
AI techniques to try to address some of
these challenges and so Jeff big up is a
professor at Carnegie Mellon University
and today he's gonna be talking to us
about applications of AI for augmenting
the sense of vision Walter lisicki is a
professor at the University of Michigan
and he'll talk about how AI technologies
can be applied to augment hearing and
finally Sean cane who's a professor at
the University of Colorado we'll talk
about how AI can augment speech and
communication and again after each of
them give their presentations we'll do a
little bit of time for individual
questions if you have a question that's
just specific to that presentation but
then as a whole the panel including
myself will be happy to discuss with you
kind of larger sauce around themes that
you see across all the presentations and
around what are the interesting
challenges you know how can a I research
inform advances in the creation of
accessible technologies and how can the
needs of accessibility really help AI
research push the boundary in setting
its agenda and defining what good
problems and metrics are so I'd like to
invite Jeff up first to share his
presentation with you about augmenting
visions
all right I'm Jeff Begum from Carnegie
Mellon University thank you Mary for the
great introduction and so I'm really
excited to be in this panel I think it's
really great that Microsoft not only is
doing a lot in accessibility but also
including us in AI and an AI oriented
summit and to me that makes a lot of
sense right because AI has the potential
to dramatically expand the possibilities
for people with disabilities making the
world more accessible and all right
people with disabilities have been among
the earliest adopters of AI technology
and have driven some of the biggest
human facing innovations in the area I
think there's a lot to learn from their
experiences I think that when we develop
AI driven approaches for mainstream use
so as AI makes it out into the world is
a lot that we can learn from the early
adopters and I think people disabilities
have been that released adopters and so
in my short talk I'm going to focus on
what we've learned by deploying a crowd
powered system for people who are blind
to answer visual questions
all right my view is just not thinking
which is pretty yeah right all right all
right so so if you think about it
developing technologies for people who
are blind should be a grand challenge
for computer vision research I think
what is more common to computer vision
as a discipline than a natural
application that reproducing in software
the perceptual ability is afforded by
the human eye and there's actually been
a lot of research in this area but
sometimes it's been a bit of an
afterthought hmm I developed this cool
new computer vision technique I wonder
if a blind person could use it I bet
they could right and so a few years ago
some students sorry it's just when I
click to click the next slide it doesn't
do that oh wow much better
yeah this was perfect okay thanks a lot
okay so a few years ago my students and
I set out to discover what could blind
people what would bond people actually
want to know if they could ask anything
and we did that by deploying this mobile
application called vizwiz and so to use
it users take a picture they speak a
question and then they they receive
answers back pretty quickly from people
we paid out on the web to answer those
questions so crowd workers great so we
deployed this application we've had more
than ten thousand users answer or ask
over a hundred thousand questions with
it there's a wide variety of question I
can't go over all of them right now but
just to give you a sense right so we
have everything from you know what does
this thermostat say how do I cook this
believe it or not you can actually find
the cooking instructions for this
packaged food here and this this photo
kind of weird there's a photo here of a
nighttime sky and it's really
interesting when we saw this somebody
was asking the same question what does
the sky look like what does this guy
look like every five minutes and we're
like what is this person doing but
around that same time we're monitoring
Twitter and we saw that somebody posted
we used I just use vizwiz to watch the
sunset right and so someone had used
vizwiz by just querying over and over
again to ask to watch the sunset which
is pretty cool other we get a little bit
of stuff that we didn't exactly intend
and discourage like that credit card
there we gets a bunch of credit cards
sent to for interpretation by the crowd
we also get a lot of appliances so this
is a coffee machine it's kind of hard to
answer in this form but we get a lot of
how do I use this how do I use this
device all right last one I think maybe
didn't work but anyway so we got a lot
of questions asked a lot of images and
we were able to package this up into a
data set so we remove those that contain
personally identifying information and
we still were able to release a data set
of nearly 50,000
questions and answers and our hope is
that this data set of real questions by
blind people in their everyday lives may
inspire computer vision researchers to
work on this problem and maybe even make
it a true Grand Challenge for computer
vision and so when we were getting
started I talked to people so in 2011 or
so I talked to computer vision
researchers I said you know what I have
this application and we're generating
this data I think it'd be really
interesting for you and they said oh wow
that's pretty cool but that is way too
hard
right because you look at the diversity
of questions and the poor quality of the
images and and whatnot and they said
it's just too hard so fortunately deep
learning has come along and the data
side is still really hard and we're
really far from being able to answer
many if not most of the questions
automatically but fortunately with deep
learning has come confidence and if
nothing else I'll take that because
people have started to work on this and
so now there's a number of papers out
have used our data set in serious ways
to address this problem and in that
includes Microsoft's own seeing AI it
was a cool new app that was released a
few days ago and so if you haven't seen
this I encourage you to check it out so
it's for the iPhone does all kinds of
cool things with answering visual
questions one of the things that the
data set allowed us to do was to kind of
understand problem areas more task
specific problem areas that blind people
wanted to know more about and so one of
those that we noticed was that a lot of
people ask questions about devices so we
got a lot of pictures of devices
printers and washing machines and coffee
makers and vending machines and things
like that and this was the the way it
works it's difficult to describe to a
person all of the different buttons that
are on an interface and it's even harder
especially as the interfaces for these
devices have become flatter so for a
blind person to independently find the
button that they might want to on an
otherwise just flat flat surface and so
we developed a system that targeted this
particular use case and it modified the
vizwiz workflow just a little bit so
user still tart started off by taking a
picture this case taking a picture of
the interface that they wanted to use
and then crowd workers instead of
answering your question would label that
interface so they provide labels for all
the different buttons on the interface
and then that allowed us to create a
computer vision model on that ran on the
phone that would tell the user as they
held the phone up what button their
their finger was under or over top of
and this works really well it
surprisingly well because we weren't
trying to solve a general computer
vision problem of answering anything out
in the world we were actually not even
trying to solve the general problem of
how do you use any any individual in
Erfurt and any interface for a device
instead we're solving the problem of
given a labelled model of this
particular interface taken from roughly
the same perspective and roughly the
same lighting conditions can you tell
the user what their fingers overtop of
so here's just a little bit of a
description of how this works
business users capture a photo often
inaccessible interface and send it to
multiple co-workers who work in parallel
to quickly label and describe elements
of the interface the business
application helps users recapture the
interface in the field of the camera and
uses it did it did it did the provision
to interactively describe the part of
the interface beneath their team
alright and like I said it works pretty
well we tried to across a number of
different kinds of interfaces so here's
just a short video of some things we
tried
everything
we're like that laughs so on the laser
cutter depending on the audience you
know sometimes people really call these
our cutter of course why not line
forcing you blades are going to straight
so I work pretty well we're hoping to
deploy it it's not that it's not that AI
computer vision couldn't you know
eventually take over this task but with
the crowd we're able to get there pretty
fast we're able to generate data that
the computer vision can then train
itself on they were actually able to
understand a little bit more about
what's important in facilitating this
kind of interaction we also modified
this slightly and instead of having the
user just take a picture of the
interface we have them take a picture of
the interface alongside a dollar bill
and there's allowed us to do two things
one is it allowed us to help the user
aim the camera because we had a
fiduciary marker of a known size and
also allowed us to help to actually
create a model that of a particular size
of the interface that so that we could
generate a tactile overlay on top of the
interface that the user could attach so
I'll show you how that works in a couple
of videos here so here's a user they're
going to take a picture of the interface
and because we have this dollar here
they're able to get some assistance and
aiming their camera actually going a
little bit back farther than just
including the dollar because they know
they have to go more than just including
the dollar charlie aiming is good let me
take their photo from this we're able to
automatically create a model model look
at spins around a tactile model that
then can be sent off to a 3d printing
service here's our three model being
printed
and then independently attached to the
device with adhesives by the eye the
blind user
so it kind of imagines a different
future where people are able to with
computer vision and a little bit of
crowd support and maybe some services
that they can that they can access on
the web create more accessible devices
in their own homes alright so by
releasing the general-purpose crowd
powered system vizwiz in this case we're
able to motivate a number of different
lines of research those computer vision
on the hard problem of answering
arbitrary general questions but also
research into sin to a system that
combines the user the crowd and computer
vision to target a specific task and
this experience has led us to some
generalizable thoughts I think for AI
system and the research in the future in
this area and so I'll illustrate this
with a sequence of videos from Justin
RoMac who is a blind blogger who pretty
early on in the project around 2011
recorded a video of himself using vizwiz
to answer a question and despite it
being a little bit old I think it
contains examples of themes that we've
extracted from our experience so here is
Justin asking his question got my
thermostat here way down and I'm gonna
take a picture here like this move it
back a little turn it around take a
picture I'm going to record my question
what does this thermostat
thing
all right so one thing we noticed pretty
quickly is that it's difficult for blind
people to take pictures independently
but despite that a good picture is vital
whether you're sending it off to a
computer vision system or to a
human-powered system and so as a result
you know we and others have done a lot
of work on blind photography supporting
blyer supporting blind photography to
enable blind people to take better
pictures and so I think the lesson here
is that it will still be a while until
AI systems are able to take over many
tasks fully but AI can be useful now to
support and amplify what users are able
to do and so in this case computer
vision has been pretty useful in helping
blind t people take better pictures even
if it's difficult to answer general
visual questions automatically right now
so here's a video here's a video of
Justin getting its first answer back for
his question of what the thermostat say
let's see in order some answers
available the IQ engines has it labeled
as a thermostat so we knew that that
doesn't do me too much good all right so
of course Justin knew that this was a
thermostat and so we had sent off the
picture first up to a system that just
told them the main object in the photo
right and surprisingly it actually
worked right as a few years ago and this
is also sort of human powered but I
think the lesson here is that there's
been a lot of effort in providing fairly
generic labels for images for instance
facebook has this really cool thing
where every photo now posted depicts -
Facebook comes along with keywords so
you can look in the alt text for
Facebook images and you'll see that they
have keywords and this is great but I
think we need to look past beyond just
providing labels and you know look at
what people actually want to know and a
lot of times the things that they know
they want want to know are much more
contextual right so working with what
the users are able to kind of infer on
their own and maybe what added
information the computer vision systems
can provide
and then finally Justin gets an answer
back from the crowd hang tight here it
did identify the temperature okay web
worker said that 75 is on the left and
71 is on the right they're not sure what
the current temperature is I can tell
you that 71 is what I hadn't said it so
what I think is interesting here is that
the crowd the human workers were also
not able to tell from the photo what the
current temperature was but they were
able to appropriately convey their
inability to do so and provide Justin
with extra information to figure it out
so here I think what's important is that
errors are important and not all created
equally so a lot of times I think we
have the tendency to report say accuracy
numbers but depending on the type of
error it can be much worse or better and
I think we also need to think about how
do we measure and express confidence
right as part of this and so for this
I'm really inspired by work that Mary
did here at Microsoft Research and
others and looking at how blind web
users reacted to different captions
provided to social media images and so
there's an example here it's a picture
of Hillary Clinton and the correct
caption or a correct caption with the
image shows Hillary Clinton walking onto
a stage in front of a large crowd of
people but if you told blind people in a
user study that the caption was actually
a man on a man doing a trick on a
skateboard at night and they didn't have
other reasons to believe that that
wasn't true they would come up with a
justification while for why that might
actually be the case right and so
there's a cost to errors and thinking
about what that cost might be and how we
minimize it and also how we can measure
and express confidence a lot of times
we've the models we've that we make for
the computer vision or other AI tasks
output some confidence value but there's
not been a lot of importance put on
making those confidence values match up
to user expectations or expressing them
in a way that users can understand so
just to summarize you know the things
that I would like to see more work on
and I think are important as we
increasingly see AI
make it into user facing applications
are systems that amplify users with AI
support instead of trying to do
everything you know figure out ways to
augment the person amplify what they're
able to do you know figure out a way to
target our work towards solving real
problems right so labels might be really
interesting and useful in some cases
but a lot of times they what we really
wanted something more contextual embrace
and understand errors and figure out
when are the error is important when are
they not
how do we reduce the cost of making
errors and part of that is probably
measuring and confidence and figuring
out how to express it well to users so
that is the end of my talk obviously
lots of people to think and you can you
can find out more at the URLs on the
screen thank you on to the next speaker
if people have a few questions for Jeff
that are specific to the work that he
just presented we can definitely do
those now so feel free to raise your
hand if you have something you'd like to
ask the microphone is going to come for
you in just a second hey Jeff I just
want to clarify in the one where you're
taking the pictures of the appliance
interface are you are you trying to
generalize from it to or to detect that
interface in the future or are you
creating data set for other people to do
that though yeah so it's a great
question so we are at the application
level only targeting recognizing that
same interface again so that that user
can use that appliance in their home or
their workplace or wherever I think as
we deploy the application so we're
hoping to do this do that within the
next few weeks our goal would be to
collect a data set of these appliances
so that it could potentially generalize
so again kind of following the path of
deploying the crowd powered system so
that we can both collect data and
understand what's important and then
hopefully engage with computer vision
researchers to make that more and more
automatic over time Thanks Hey great
talk um Motion's wondering are there any
other caption mode and taking a photo
right because it
apparently you know seems like the wrong
with energy flow blind person enters
cruise great question so yeah taking a
photo is hard so why don't we do
something else right um so certainly we
and others have explored things like
video or streaming video as a way to
capture capture information I think it's
probably difficult to get out of the
visual realm altogether because that's
kind of the what needs to be what we
need to provide access to but making it
more air resistant is various ways of
you know just having them kind of scan
the phone around so that doesn't matter
exactly what they're looking at as long
as sometimes they're looking at the
right thing
and the other the other thing I should
mention is I've mostly been targeting
completely blind users but people like
sherry hasn't caught here and the
audience have looked at technology for
low vision users for instance there you
can much more again playing off the
theme of you know it's not just the
technology that has to provide the
answer it's a combination of the user
and the technology how do you leverage
the vision the person has to help maybe
capture the right information so that
then some other system or the user can
provide more information Jeff thank you
this is great work I hadn't seen this
before this is fantastic um I understand
surveillance concerns but does anyone
looking about utilizing cameras in
public settings and maybe Minority
Report
esque but essentially zooming in and
tapping those cameras to solve the
problem of a blind person trying to take
a picture but understand their
orientation and take advantage of that
infrastructure yeah that's a fascinating
question so we have another project that
I did not talk about here today called
sensors and which we are deploying many
of these cameras and using a crowd and
computer vision approach to help
understand them interpret them I think
probably right now the reason not a lot
of people are doing that is just because
access to the cameras are probably there
increasingly but access to them is
difficult but it sounds it's a
fascinating idea of how you could
leverage the public camera as an
infrastructure as well
since our probably related deserve
richer banks are under a design team for
the MSR cambridge lab i'm wondering what
contacts blind people are uncomfortable
taking photos you know sir is there a
lack of faces for example in your own
corpus and so on yeah it's a great
question so it's an interesting to look
at despite the fact that we have very
clearly told the users in our our
studies that the questions are being
sent off to people what they choose to
take photos of we we asked them not to
take photos of people's faces or other
personal identifying information
sometimes it appears that they decided
to do that anyway and that might be
because you know they were in a settings
a public setting where they didn't seem
to they didn't think there was a problem
in doing that it might be because they
were making kind of a Privacy
Information access trade-off which is
really interesting right so the credit
card might be a good example of that I
don't necessarily want my credit card up
on the web but at the same time I want
to know what the numbers say on it and
so how do I make that kind of a
trade-off and of course also because of
these problems with taking good photos
it's also the case that you can
accidentally capture private information
I think that's the most worrisome for us
and Walter the sekki here and I and
other people have thought about well how
do you design computer vision or
computer human computation workflows
that both leverage the image interpret e
of people while still not providing them
complete access to an image we have an H
comp paper coming out essentially
involving showing them a very highly
zoomed in version
gradually zooming out as you say there's
no you there's no personal identifying
information in the in the photo but it's
a hard problem just a question and sort
of a capture side of things you know try
to capture from cameras in the
environment you could do from your cell
phone which I get their own head there's
also a lot of cameras like wide-angle
very high resolution cameras guess
there's a big privacy issue I mean just
a question about in that sort of space
ideal sort of imaging system for blind
photography that balances some
these issues and the key thing is about
privacy and then intentionality as
opposed to always on full resolute you
know full resolution to do any task
how do those trade oh yeah so it's a
great question what would be the ideal
I'll say that especially I think in
accessibility we tend to target
commodity devices because I think we
feel this this desire to make sure that
whatever we do even though we're doing
research has at least a potential for
kind of real term or near-term impact
right and especially the kind of work
here where we want to put it out in the
hands of actual users so that we can see
what they do with it any hardware
requirements we make beyond having say
an iPhone reduces who could do it right
but beyond that thinking about what the
ideal case is right it very likely could
be if we had a high-resolution camera
you know on you know something like a
you know how it had mounted that had
head mounted camera that could maybe not
always be transmitting but could save a
little buffer so that if somebody had a
question about something that they just
looked at or we're near they could ask
it that might be good I think there's a
whole lot of other problems that that
introduces about you know how you get to
somebody does actually wear this camera
like you know what's the cost of the
camera all these other things but
probably yeah better information more
information would be would be more
useful thank you Jeff so next I'll
Walter is going to speak with us and
Walter we'll be talking about the
application of AI to hearing an audio
accessibility
all right
that work right great and I will see if
I can reclaim a few minutes in the
interest of panel discussion so yeah so
today I'm going to be talking about how
we can think about supporting audio
accessibility right with intelligent
systems and more specifically
intelligent systems that in the near
term are going to be crowd powered so
I'm going to kind of move into a
different domain than what Jeff was
looking at but a lot of the approaches
are going to be similarly inspired so if
you think about kind of at a high level
there are three different categories of
audio accessibility right you might have
a deaf or hard-of-hearing user who wants
to be able to access speech that might
be somebody standing up in front of a
room talking it might be dialog with a
peer or a family member or it might be
you know some kind of verbal
announcement beyond that you know we
also have events that happen all the
time the chimes that are playing out in
the hallway to get us all to come in and
and actually listen to these talks an
alert on your phone even a fire alarm or
something like that would would fall
into this category of events and we
don't have to be able to understand
human language for those but we do have
to understand the context behind that
event and when the one noise maker
essentially is is important to alert a
user to and then finally even if we kind
of can access the audio itself language
can make things inaccessible in its own
right either
you know the person does not speak the
same language as the other as the person
speaking or even the language to be just
too too complicated
so think about legalese mosha most of us
suffer from some inability to understand
legally at one level or another for
somebody with a cognitive impairment
this might be amplified so what I'm
going to focus on today while there are
lots of interesting AI applications
across this whole range and actually
even some crowdfire systems that have
tackled each of these I'm really going
to focus today on on trying to
understand speech and trying to access
speech even for a deaf or
hard-of-hearing person so what's the
real goal here I'm going to be talking
about this in the context of real-time
speech transcription so we really want
to take a speaker
was sending somewhere in a live setting
and be able to understand what they're
saying convert what they're saying to
written text within usually about five
seconds less would be better but if we
want to be able to pair what somebody's
saying with a visual content or be able
to pair it what somebody's saying with
you know the ability to actually
interject and and bring up another point
we need to be really really fast so the
dream is that we want something to be
able to pull out their phone push a
button and immediately get captions
unfortunately there are a number of
things that that stop us from being able
to do that too easily one thing for one
thing the speaker is very one speaker
has a different accent than another
different speech patterns prosody the
actual speed of the language itself is
even the same person has a cold one day
and not the next right that might change
had the audio signal that that is
actually arriving to system the
environment itself varies the speaking
in this room is very different than
speaking in my office if I'm talking to
somebody else there's a different level
of echo different distance from speakers
maybe amplification through three
speakers etc so we want to think about
these acoustic properties and the
challenges they present even the
settings even if it's the same place the
same speaker the microphone might be
differently oriented they might be in a
different place I might be pacing around
if I wasn't miked up directly might be
pacing around and kind of the direction
of my speech will vary and finally it
looks like it ate one of my bullet
points so natural language is weird so
an afro and kinds of variability of
language adds a lot of complexity in its
own right and really takes the content
underlying the signal the speech signal
itself beyond what the computer can
understand right now but my next bullet
point was its natural languages weird
spoken language is even weirder
we interject things we pause we kind of
redact what we just said and just say
okay never mind not that and and replace
it with something else so we have these
even more varied language patterns in
speech than we do in just written
natural language
okay so great so we're going to take a
crowdsourcing approach to bridging this
gap so we can't currently use automatic
speech recognition to solve the
captioning problem in realistic settings
there are plenty of cases where I can
pull out my phone I can transcribe a
short sentence or to text message it
works pretty well it even works these
days with thanks to deep learning you
know pretty well in a slightly varied
environments but it's still the same
microphone it's the same speaker and if
you start to change a lot of the the
types of the challenges that we saw on
the last slide which really do come up
when you want a student to be able to
walk into any lecture or room and put
down their phone and be able to get
captions we really beyond what automatic
speech recognition alone can do with
high accuracy so we're going to think
about the crowd as a way to bridge this
gap and the benefit is that people
understand speech pretty well by and
large some of these variations can can
affect people's ability understand it as
well but by and large we communicate
with one another
smoothly in person and that's
essentially what we're trying to capture
here we can understand the meaning
behind language we can understand how
the conversation involves when I think
of robertinho gave a great example of an
interjection that you know we wouldn't
actually use the the yelling of the kids
as context for the rest of the
interaction so people are really good at
this the problem is there's actually
kind of a motor limitation if we want
people to sit there and type out what
they're hearing you can't type fast
enough right it would require you know
thousands of key presses a minute and on
a QWERTY keyboard it's really not not
viable right now so the accommodations
that are accepted that are available
right now for providing speech access
are typically highly trained
professionals who have using a special
keyboard and trained for years to be
able to type fast enough and kind of
listen and type at the same time if I
give this to it this has to a average
person just you know pick somebody from
the audience which I won't do I promise
I usually get about 10 to 20 percent of
what's actually being said and the real
problem is
previous to this work we didn't know
what to do with that right having 10
people type different pieces of a
conversation does not yield something
that's actually useful as an
accessibility tool I can't provide
somebody 10th Street 10 streams of
partial information and say well good
luck with it we have to do know that
people can eventually reconstruct these
things they can't do it in real time
it's too confusing it's too messy of
attack so that's where we want
computation to be able to help us
coordinate so we have the system called
scribe which is a tool that allows you
no student or somebody in the classroom
to pull out their phone stream audio to
our back-end server the server that
actually distributes this work of
captioning what what the audio contains
to a set of crowd workers so we're
distributing the workload for multiple
people and then the challenge becomes
how do we get that work how do we get
those partial captions back into one
piece so we're going to have a merging
process that then is able to return a
single stream of audio captions about
three or four seconds okay but like I
said this is hard so how do we actually
get people to do this instead of asking
everyone to just type stuff we're going
to take at the high level a kind of a
round robin approach so each person will
hear a short segment of audio maybe two
or three seconds long right one phrase
essentially and they'll start typing out
what they heard now it will take him
longer than the two or three seconds
that they actually had to listen to it
for which is why this is hard in the
first place but while they're typing
we'll have somebody else come and type
the next two or three second and so on
and so forth and we can kind of vary
this based on the size of our crowd and
actually reduce the workload on each
individual by the time you know other
folks in our new set of three work crowd
workers here have completed or have
heard their segments then the first
person has completed their task an
actually can take another two or three
seconds of audio and start to type that
so that everybody's kind of leapfrogging
over one another to type small pieces at
a time and so the interface for doing
this is relatively simple so they have
workers come to our task
these can be students in
classroom these can be Mechanical Turk
workers that we recruit online they can
be any other kind of crowd platform or
group of interested people who want to
help caption and they're able to type in
this interface so you can see a couple
things one there's some feedback on if
they're doing a good job so if we
recognize that multiple people are for
the same segment typing the same word
then we kind of lock it in and we
confirm that that seems like a
reasonable thing to say we also so we
have kind of long-term running feedback
through the points this animates upward
so you see what was typed in the past
but it slowly fades away over time and
one interesting thing is we actually
have the this text lock in
so I mentioned you know having latency
of only a few seconds really matters
what we don't want is people going back
and spending a lot of time editing every
little typo that they make right so
instead we encourage people to just type
through get what they can and if they
miss something or if they type something
a little bit incorrectly don't worry
about it and what we're actually going
to do is have multiple people complete
the same segment now in parallel and by
doing that we can actually run a
multiple sequence alignment process over
the results figure out how the the
different captions can be stitched back
together and then merge that into a
higher-quality caption that any one
individual could have created alone so
unlike can the vizwiz model where you're
getting multiple different answers from
different people and as long as one of
them is good enough you're you're set
here we actually want a synthesis answer
that's better than any individual in our
crowd could have generated a lot and so
this actually performs quite well we're
able to recall about 95% of what a
speaker in our data set was actually
saying and we can merge it back together
with about 87 percent precision and
importantly we can do this all in a per
word with a per word latency of just
under three seconds now so this is
actually on par and sometimes even
better than a professional captionists
it's because this workload has been
distributed over so many different
people right now everybody doesn't have
to be lightning-fast for a long period
of time they just need to be able to
type their few words quickly
okay now for those kind of doing the
numbers on their hands at home um if you
say what I thought speech recognition
was 99% accurate in all domains well the
problem is though it's not in the
domains that we're looking at untrained
on a speaker in a new setting that we
just kind of tuck it into on-demand we
were getting less than 50% accuracy at
the time of this work and this is a
couple years ago at this point I'm sure
that number will have improved but we're
still not seeing anything near 90
percent in these kind of wild-west
domains of anywhere you open you start
transcribing with your phone look at the
way so great now this general structure
not just provides us a way to actually
get captions to deaf and hard of hearing
people immediately right we've actually
been able to demo this at the KY
conference where we had people in the
audience participate as captioner right
actually we're able to provide captions
for the sessions that were going on but
doesn't just give us the ability to
solve this problem today it also gives
us kind of a framework for scaffolding
the development of better AI so one nice
thing is we're assuming that each of our
contributors contributors here is
imperfect right and it doesn't we're not
making any assumed assumptions that
they're human we could we could add
error models and things like that but we
can also throw in an automatic speech
recognition system right as speech
recognition gets better or if we hit a
domain in which it actually performs
pretty well then you know this one
automated unit in the middle might be
able to produce most of the captions at
high with high accuracy right and as
this becomes true we kind of diminish
the amount of human effort required to
accomplish the task at hand okay
and we do this without relying on the
system being perfect right it doesn't
need to either work or we have to use
two percent people right we can mix
these two it could be a pretty good
system for speech recognition which
saves us from having to have you know
two other workers maybe one other person
is enough to to fill in the gaps and
correct the errors and so
all right so because in summary this
shows us a way that we can actually
create systems that let people
collectively outperform any constituent
individual on on streaming tasks and
this is more general than just audio we
can think about the same kind of
alignment methods on a stream of
discrete input we also start to lower
the barrier to actually helping with
this task right before you were either
an expert or you weren't helpful now I
can get a bunch of people together who
have the ability to just type it at a
regular speed and collectively they can
contribute to this problem this means
that now friends peers fellow students
loved ones caregivers whoever else might
be able to actually provide support
because of what we're able to do in
terms of aggregating and synthesizing
their input together
this also means that we can pull in
domain experts right if you think about
somebody who has trained their entire
life to be a captionist versus someone
who is a fellow student in the class for
general class right like just pick one
out of a hat it the student in the class
probably has a lot more domain expertise
on understanding what's going on what's
being talked about what the term
actually was that was being said or or
what was meant by something that was set
incorrectly or pronounced incorrectly
and you know now we can actually
leverage domain experts not just a kind
of task expert and finally as we saw
this provides kind of a way for training
ASR systems on the fly that we can use
to to generate essentially living data
pipelines right now we can deploy these
systems first get them in in place
helping people and then the only thing
that changes over time is the the
intermixing of how much human support is
needed and how much AI can do instead of
saying look we can't provide that
service or that access technology until
a certain point down the road where we
have the technology to automate it well
enough all right so on that thank you
specifics for Walters presentation we
can we can take those now anthony
hornoff university of oregon nice work
have you thought about using cognitive
modeling to split up the text because
there's a lot of great typing models for
example out there that Bonnie John has
done I mean I'm sure you have some means
of chopping them up most most
effectively most efficiently yeah so we
certainly have the kind of
infrastructure in place for taking these
kinds of models and trying to figure out
how to chunk units that people could
more easily understand certainly if you
capture a phrase right that's going to
be easier for one person to caption that
it is if I give you really an arbitrary
segment um we I don't have numbers for
you offhand on exactly what the right
approach is there we kind of anecdotally
played with a number of them but I think
there's a lot more interesting work to
be done there right yes and so we have
done some work on adaptively learning
how fast each individual types and
customizing the length of the segment to
their but we still don't do anything to
try to plan ahead on like kind of the
shift to figure out what those the
exactly phrasal I'm in it so yeah but
thank really cool work and a really good
point you made about it might be
generalizable to other things it sort of
seems like maybe a framework for
generalized multi-threaded crowd
sourcing or paralyzed competing zamana
human computing in that sort of a
setting it sort of seemed like you know
one part that you've addressed here is
sorta like how you paralyze right you
take a task it's you know requires more
computation than a single person or more
throughput than a single person has and
break it up to multiple people it seems
like in that setting also a generalized
setting for doing that kind of task
error correction would be sort of a key
part and we'll put that I was a little
surprised that you didn't talk about or
maybe you could comment on it is that it
seems like after you've generated this
then it will be very natural to have a
person read through
and then correct for you no comment or
entity errors or things they need fix up
any comment of it yeah so we have played
with having kind of near real-time
processes so not within this five-second
bound but thinking about well what about
15-20 seconds later right if we can get
rid of all of the any errors that were
left in the initial transcription um
that's I think he wants the mic back
that would be one way to think about the
secondary process the other thing is
actually using ASR as the initial base
source of captions and then having
people follow up and do the corrections
on the fly and that turns out the short
version is that turns out to depend
heavily on how accurate the speech
recognition system was at the beginning
so we have some work that shows passed
some threshold you can actually add
benefit by having people just fix what
the computer guessed but below that you
actually slowed them down worse than if
you hadn't given them anything at all so
it's kind of a careful trade-off that
has to be that has to be made it means
just a quick polyp on it so you know you
break it up into partial sentences and
get people to transcribe those and then
put them together it just sort of seems
like the whole sort of semantics around
a whole sentence like no one has access
to that that would seem like a very
natural first order error correction
that seems to be missing in a system
that only works on partial sentences or
yeah something corrects for that so
there's actually yeah there's an
important piece there where we don't
actually for the segments that you're
not asked to type we don't actually hide
that content so it is important for
people to listen to the entire audio
stream even if they're only responsible
for typing pieces of that and again just
kind of anecdotally if we slice up the
audio into actual three-second segments
and then mute everything else people
start to make a lot of the same errors
that speech recognition does right
because they're basically just working
from the signal again this is great work
one of the questions is now that you
have a team approach this could you
combine that with voting approaches so
is there a way of getting people
estimating effect so you could try to
get whether people being sarcastic or
giddy or deadpan and if you have
multiple people transcribing now you
have multiple votes right so we've done
a little bit of that actual
so we have a tool called glance that
actually allows you to do behavioral
annotations on video and there it's the
exact same kind of thing where we try to
figure out more accurate bounds on the
event then one person could come up with
but then we can actually aggregate the
subjective judgments that they're
issuing for each each point yeah which
is available soon Bruce Walker Georgia
Tech general question when you have more
and more volunteers or workers in the
crowdsource sort of following on Beth's
point you could have different people
doing different having different
expertise right so you could have people
who are familiar with that accent you
have people who are familiar with that
terminology or that jargon or that
domain get it people are familiar with
and our task with getting the the effect
or sarcasm or and these other local
regional jokes or anything like that and
and all be doing that in parallel and
then stitching that together there's a
general comment to un de Jeff and others
is is that being done is this sort of
splitting up the crowd into sort of
expertise subsets and then stitching it
together is that something that's we're
seeing yet so we're starting to see a
little bit of focus on on expertise
usually more holistic experts how do you
bring an expert who knows that role to a
job that only they can do here it's a
little bit different right you have a
different modifier on your expertise so
you're able to type but also you know
something about the dialect or also you
know something about that content I
think right now that has mostly been
relegated to a recruiting problem so how
do you find people who would fit
together you might use the same approach
I that would be a little naive to
actually maximize benefit from that but
I don't think there's been as much work
at this point actually focusing on on
how you use that that modifiers those
modifiers on expertise yeah a good idea
though we're thinking about it from the
tool side bill how do you divide the
tools up and they give everybody a
different type of tool to accomplish the
same task they all come back to
something that said that's essentially
inducing that variation
yeah hey Walter I'm curious whether when
I'm typing on the piece that I'm
transcribing and I'm starting to hear
the next bit does that interfere and
have you thought about actually muting
it and then playing fast to catch up so
that I have kind of focused and then I
catch up to it so what we do right now
yes it does throw people off a little
bit at those boundary words what we tend
to try to do is be very inclusive and
just say if you weren't sure exactly
where it it marked the ending of your
segment just include it that's only a
fractional answer to your question so
what we also do is usually instead of
muting it all together we give you that
little bit of focus by decreasing the
audio level right and so you would get a
very salient in the same audio stream
you get kind of very salient indicator
that you are not responsible for the
content that you listening to now but
are able to kind of follow along as much
as you can listen the other thing is
that we've done exactly that we've
slowed things down and sped them back up
and it turns out that this can actually
change the behavior that people exhibit
when they're captioning and so when you
get double digit improvements and
precision recall and surprisingly
latency so we get faster when we slow
people down because you're able to keep
up forward instead of like kind of
memorizing that segment and typing a
letter so yeah thank you all sir all
right and next up Sean cane from the
University of Colorado is going to talk
about speech and communication
disabilities and the applicability of AI
to those domains I told the camera crew
I was not going to stand here I was
going to stand over there but I changed
my mindset sorry about that
hi everybody so thanks for having me
here and Mary said I'm going to talk
about how we can think about AI and to
support people with a wide range of
communications impairments and
disabilities and if take anything away
like my point is to say that this is
actually a problem where there's so much
opportunity to actually address issues
and
that looking at how to support someone
who has difficulty communicating about
the world around them there are
interesting sub problems in almost any
area of CS research in terms of
understanding the environment in terms
of understanding language terms of HCI
in user input and output so I'm going to
just talk a little bit about some of the
problems and I'll tell you about some of
the work we've done to date looking at
some of these issues start with a very
brief vocabulary lesson to orient us all
to give you a sense of what are the
sorts of technologies that are already
out there and so I'll talk about AAC
during the this talk so we say a is
augmentative and alternative
communication if you have any experience
with this technology you might see
something a bit like my laser aims not
very good with this symbol based menu
you'll see at the top there so for
someone who might have difficulty typing
or writing you can have symbol based
communications we also see more typing
based input and I'll share some examples
of that later on and I just want to
point out that there's a wide range of
what sorts of technologies and what
sorts of interactions you might see
using AAC and to give you a sense of the
population so estimated about two
million people in the US so a little bit
less than one out of a hundred people
would be severely communication and
parroted we use need to use that sort of
technology for their everyday life and
again when we think about who would
actually use this we see a really wide
range of challenges so we think about
physical disabilities so I mean severe
ataxia speech or ALS where the cognitive
abilities are not impaired but the
ability to actually articulate speech is
we've done some work looking at
linguistic conditions such as aphasia
which might may or may not have a
cognitive component but unless they have
component around processing language we
also look at cognitive and intellectual
disabilities autism spectrum disorders
and so forth so again when I say there's
a lot of different subproblems here you
can imagine just looking through the set
that there are quite some differences in
terms of how you would actually do this
and some of the work we we've looked at
how can we apply some of this work
outside of people with disabilities so
if you think about typically a
functioning adults who might be learning
a new language we might learn a lot
about efficient text input and
communication could be useful and NAC
but also in that in the general
population and just to give a sense of
how this impact people so often if you
have a more severe communication
impairment this is this could be the
barrier between participation and public
life or the lack of there so going to a
work school traveling and if you are
unable to communicate you're you often
unable to do these things and this can
be despite the ability to do so right so
if you have the cognitive capabilities
but aren't able to articulate speech
you're not going to be able to
participate in these ways and some of
the work we've done recently and in
collaboration with Mary Ann with MS are
looking at the effects of communication
technologies on one's identity
so if you we've done some work with
people with ALS for instance and if you
think about for example like how
embarrassed you might be if you call
someone by the wrong name or what you
know what people might think if you do
so all of these issues can affect
someone who's using AAC even more so so
the importance that you represent one as
an as a confident independent adult and
to represent one's own personality this
this paper here talked about some of
these issues and again this technology
can be the difference between
participating in public life and not
here's an image of Steve Gleason who has
ALS and he says until there's a medical
treatment or a cure for ALS technology
can be a cure and you can see in his in
this image he's I typing using an eye
tracker so did some work looking at
particular people with ALS who have
their full cognitive capabilities
linguistic capabilities but don't have
aren't able to move the rest of their
bodies all right so to give a sense of
how this is actually again it could be
useful and how AI it can help address
some of these issues as I said this is a
number of sub challenges that are quite
interesting and there's quite a lot of
opportunity here so if we look at the
challenges of
human-computer interaction challenges
for AAC and give us a sense of how we
might address some of these issues and
if you think about your typical everyday
communication the goal is to be able to
support real-time communication about
any possible topic right we might start
talking about communication in AI but if
the conversation goes in a different
direction we want to be prepared for
that there are some significant input
challenges and throughput challenges
around AAC so for example if we look at
I give typing most studies show about 20
words per minute input versus and
typical conversation about 180 words per
minute so there's just not only a
quantitative gaps that are really
qualitative gap in terms of one's
ability to communicate and as I
mentioned some of the work we've done
recently is looking at this notion of
authentic communication so it's not
enough just to say the right words and
even in the right order but we want to
we represent ourselves through our
communication so it's actually quite
important that how we express things
affects our reflects our mood who we are
what we see as our personality and the
real opportunity for AI is in
understanding that context so
understanding the context of the person
of the environment and their their
communication preferences so I'll share
a few brief examples on how we have
actually used context as a way to enable
more efficient communication so if we
look at some of the factors we might
think of we need to know a lot about
this speaker so we might want to know
their conversation style what they know
what they're doing we also often want to
know about the conversation partner and
a lot of work today has looked at this
issue of environment so how do we
understand what's happening in this
situation to help us enable more
efficient communication and as with Jeff
and Walters work we have looked at
humans in the loop and we might think of
humans in the loop as being a good way
to solve some of these issues because
humans tend to be very good at
communication so we've looked at for
example annotating images of the
environment and using having humans
suggest what someone might want to say
about that but as with the other
examples
there are some issues where humans in
the loop are just not going to work very
well so if you think about conversations
about private and sensitive information
there going to be some conversations
that you just don't want to have anybody
outside of that conversation aware of it
again this issue of latency so if we
have very fast spoken conversations what
we've seen in our work to date is if
someone can't keep up with this this
rate of communication often there the
result is they withdraw from
conversations right so if everybody
around you is speaking out 180 words per
minute and you're speaking at ten or
twenty it's really difficult to
participate in that conversation and
what we have seen is it is very
difficult for everyone else to adapt to
that style of communication so we often
just see people always drawing and I
think there's a big argument for all
populations of people with disabilities
but here of the notion of independence
and if we're using technology to support
independence of different in many ways
than having a person in the loop all
right so I'm briefly going to describe
two systems that we've developed to look
at some of these aspects of of context
and other links to paper so you can
learn more about them if you're
interested and so again if we think back
about the ways that the context that
we're in shapes our conversation some of
the early work in this area looked at
who where we are and who we're talking
to right so a lot of what guides our
conversation is about who who we are
interacting with and to look at some of
this we developed the system a few years
ago which was looking at how do we
actually include this in the interface
so this is work with people with aphasia
and guru well that was sorry about that
there's audio in that company actually
can I need this sorry about that
in room you know how to do a house oh
can you oh sorry about that
oh thank you yeah so you know the
environment terrific affects our ability
to communicate clearly and so this is
worth looking at people working with
people with aphasia and as I mentioned
before there are quite a lot of
individual differences in terms of how
we think about designing these tools and
this work one of this the strong pieces
of feedback
actually had was looking through menus
and interacting with the interface is
extremely taxing for this population and
so if we have a system like this it's a
symbol based communication tool well we
want to enable a lot of conversation
topics to talk about whatever you might
like which means very long lists of
things that you might say and so the
work here is to look at how can we
actually design an interface that will
trim down the options or allow the
person using the technology to focus on
technologies of interest and so if you
go to this link here there's quite a lot
of description about how we develop the
system got feedback one of the
challenges I'll talk about in a minute
also is collecting feedback from people
who are severely communication impaired
and collecting data in general is a real
challenge and so we looked at this
concept of using location and people
this general framework was well-received
there were a lot of challenges around
how do we actually enable the user to
switch between contexts and the
trade-offs between automatically
adapting a context which is easier but
confusing versus more manual selection
of I'm talking to Mary and now I want to
talk about Harry Potter for instance so
we developed a few different versions of
this system there's actually some also
some really great follow-up work from
Kristin Williams and Leigh Ostin later
where they looked at the similar
techniques on different form factors so
like a head mounted display and the
other work I just want to draw your
attention to is thinking about local
environment as context and this is a
interesting case where advances that are
happening in other areas of AI and even
AI for accessibility give us some
opportunity for enhancing communication
we see here an image of the produce
aisle at the supermarket with terms tags
and then it's a little difficult to see
the text is a bit small there but
discussion prompt around those those
objects so we we just presented this
work at the dis conference about a month
ago but we were looking in particular at
how do we and in this case how do we
support people with eye gaze typing so
these are individuals with ALS
again have full linguistic or cognitive
capabilities but have this really really
really slow input rate so how can we
make the system predict better what I
might want to talk about and we might
say that the objects in our environment
are a source for that so I'm going to
talk about this water bottle or the
remote or what have you and so we built
some prototypes that used Microsoft
cognitive services to and can't be
cameras on the beach devices actually to
capture objects in the environment so
that then you could use this as either
prediction for typing as you see here or
and it separately is a way to have
generate full sentences so if we get
this part right and we can actually
generate a full sentence that it's
something that someone might want to say
we can drastically reduce the amount of
effort required to to communicate and so
this link here will probably tell you
more about the paper in terms of how we
developed the system and some of the
context where this could be useful all
right so I want to wrap up just by
directing our attention to some of the
the opportunities and challenges here so
our work here says that there's quite a
lot of potential in having communication
devices that are smarter and that know
more about the environment but there are
some significant challenges and if we
look at the previous examples of
accessibility for vision and for audio
we see that there's quite a lot of work
in understanding what's going on here we
have the additional challenge of taking
that and turning it into something
that's actionable how do we understand
how can we communicate about this what
you might note from this from these
examples is where we do have this
challenge around collecting feedback in
collecting data so there is a there are
some really interesting problems here
around how do you understand maybe how
these minor variations in a user
interface or in a prediction algorithm
can affect a person well this can be
especially challenging if they
communicate very rarely and slowly and
with quite a lot of errors
so both collecting the data to help us
understand how to build these systems
but also how do we assess and and for
the users how do they assess whether
adopting this new tool could help them
as a real challenge so in the context of
AI there are some really exciting
problems here again anywhere we can
increase our understanding of the
environment we can use this to help
support communication so any new
channels that we might have in terms of
understanding the context understanding
a conversation or a group of people and
there are some interesting opportunities
around fusing these different contextual
data sources right so if my system
detects that I have a book the
conversation around that book is going
to vary quite a bit depending on whether
I'm at the library whether I'm in my
book club and again this notion of
authentic communication so once we
understand what's going on in the
environment and what types of
interactions we might an individual
might want to have this challenge of now
how do we present that in a way that's
authentic to how the person sees
themselves on how they communicate and
finally this challenge of how do we
assess interventions and how do we guide
design with limited data and limited
feedback so to end the cycle to say I
think this is a really exciting area I
hope you'll take a moment to think about
maybe how some of your work could be
adapted to this space and move on to the
rest of our Q&A so thanks thank you and
again if people have questions
specifically about the speech and
communication devices let's take those
before we move on to the whole panel
thank you very much for a great talk I'm
Helen mang tiny dealership Hong Kong I'm
curious you mentioned about expressive
AAC and you did the example of having a
conversational partner an option of
choosing which conversational partner
but you also mentioned using emoticons
and social context so I'm wondering
whether what kind of social context are
you thinking about what yeah right
categorize that hmm well one thing we've
we've seen in some of the work we've
done the interviews with people who use
speech generating devices and their
families there are real differences
between for example if you're
communicating with someone who is who
understands working with someone with
this kind of disability versus not and
that's a that's a quite different one
thing we saw on some of the
some of the work around people with
aphasia is the amount of preparation
they would do so if you were going to
talk to someone to say oh hi I have
aphasia you know you might have this
written on a card
I'm intellectually capable but here's
how you communicate so there's there's
some setup there in terms of maybe
understanding known versus unknown and
then we've also seen some challenges
around group size and that really
affects the ability to communicate so so
there's some around the structure of the
group and also I know where we can
leverage of conversational scripts so
that's always an opportunity if we know
if you go to the supermarket and you
check out the speech transactions are
pretty Universal across every time you
go to the supermarket so if we can
accelerate some of that that could be an
opportunity as well so I show them very
nice work thank you I'm some time trying
to understand team talk a little bit
better assume you have a corpus of 400
hours of YouTube videos or how-to videos
that have subtitles and that have the
objects that you can see in the video
saying oh this is how you operate a
printer this is how you change the
wheels of a car and you can recognize
that there's a wheel there's a car would
that be sort of the setting that you
that you think about it would it be
interesting it could be as a source of
input so here in this case we were
thinking about actually having the
camera on the speech generating device
and so capturing everything around you
and using that to start conversation I
think one thing that one one feature
there the useful is just more data about
there kinds of interactions with objects
so can we actually understand one piece
of feedback that we saw is you know I
can recognize that this is a coffee cup
but actually the interesting thing is
not to say coffee cup right you actually
want to say like oh this coffee is
really good or so tired I really needs
coffee right so so there's a lot of
human-to-human communication that and
there are data sources that we can look
at so we looking at mining news stories
or mining fiction or other kinds of
things could help us understand
interactions around objects right but
the important thing is that the thing
that person was talking about is visual
it's visible in these surroundings and
you have a camera stream and anything
that supports that would be sort of what
you're talking about
yeah and one thing we haven't looked at
directly yet but is how do you position
the device again we're often working
with people who have severe mobility
limitations as well and so if the camera
is not capturing what the objects and
what other things can be used in terms
of maybe inferring if I see you know one
object and this is often we see this as
well those kinds of things so increasing
that understanding could really increase
the benefit of this kind of system any
additional questions oh great I I know
any free doping from Oregon Health and
Science University and you raise the
question of access so are you just
dealing with direct selection either
through AI or through pointing right now
for people with physical impairment yes
so for these systems we in the first
example we used touch and then in the
second example was I gaze input and so
this was one of the challenges that
we've seen is how integrating these
types of prototypes with systems that
people are using and so there's a lot of
extra effort in terms of if you have
someone for example using switch access
or some other types of input I think
we're still thinking a lot about how do
you actually get these this technology
out in the field even to collect data
not necessarily as a full time solution
that answer your question
okay thank you
[Applause]
bring this back up so so I put together
some questions that I thought might be
interesting for the panelists to discuss
that bridge all of these themes and
those are up on the big screen but I
think before we prioritize the questions
I thought of it's better to prioritize
the questions the audience might have
for the panel as a whole and if any of
these ones strikes your fancy then feel
free to to reappropriation
so if you have questions that you'd like
to ask the panelists more generally
about an accessibility please raise your
hand in the microphone
we'll come around and indicate if you
want the whole panel to answer or if
you're directing to a particular person
I got the microphone hi this is that
question for the whole panel I think
this panel was about using AI to support
accessibility and I'm interested kind of
an opposite question which is that as
devices are now having AI capabilities
how does that exacerbate the
accessibility issues so for example cars
you should just have buttons and dials
and things like that that you can touch
but now there's a whole tablet in front
of you and also algorithms might want to
communicate something quite complicated
that they can't do with speech right
maybe they want to show you a graph now
about you know how it makes its decision
so how are we going to do with those
four you know vision speech and
communication issues I think every new
technology era sense has tended to
introduce new accessibility problems and
unfortunately too often we're playing
catch-up
I think it's increasingly true that you
know at least in research there is a
growing field that is kind of tackling
these things potentially a little bit
earlier I mean we're still behind so you
know every new internet of thing device
that's decides that it's cheaper to have
a speech input rather than a screen for
instance is likely and accessible to the
deaf person so you know we have a
project now that is trying to play
catch-up there on how do you enable a
deaf person to interact with an Internet
of Things device that only accepts
speech but those devices are already out
there right or the work that I presented
about the appliances right it it's
fancier now to have touchscreens on
everything but those touchscreens are
are smooth and even though the iPhone
has all this really nice software on it
that allows accessibility most of these
cheaper you know mic refusing right your
microwave probably doesn't right and so
we are playing catch-up a lot and it's
not clear it's not clear how to
change that I think in certain domains
right there's certainly legislation
that's happening that's making it so if
you go into say an educational institute
at least theoretically you have to be
accessible right so that might be one
answer there's technology that's been
developed it's more general-purpose
right like seeing AI is coming out which
is cool and like other things that might
make it so that you can use technology
to solve the inaccessible technology
problem but it's so it's still a problem
and it's and we don't have a good way to
get ahead of it which i think is would
be the dream of a lot of us yeah i would
add to that I think with AI systems in
general you know all AI systems make a
bunch of assumptions right about the
user or the environment where they have
models right models of the user and
these systems are only as good or
generalizable as the models are and if
the people designing AI systems forget
about the 20% of the population that has
different sensory or motor or cognitive
abilities than the the models will not
be accurate for a large subset of users
and I think that that's an important
problem for us as leaders in this field
to keep in mind and make sure that we
kind of get ahead of in what we build
yeah yeah so adding to that I think the
idea that you have to design for anymore
you kind of have to this idea of
universal design or access ability based
design for AI systems in the same way
that you would for existing systems is
is certainly going to be true I think
where there's a little bit of hope to me
at least is that a lot of at least in
interaction what AI has been you know
targeting or promising or whatever you
want to phrase that it has been a more
naturalistic interaction and usually
that cuts across more different modes so
we have a little bit more flexibility in
some sense in some of these newer
technologies that if the system is
really intelligent right then we can be
more adaptive we can better fit what the
user is actually able to do with the
interface in a way that maybe wasn't
true
when the Microsoft of the Blin the
Microsoft when the microwave went to
flat buttons right the buttons kind of
provided no additional way to to adapt
in a way that the interface noise
couldn't so there's maybe a little bit
of silver lining they're not just new
stuff but new more adaptive stuff
alright I just actually wanted to add on
to what Mary said a little bit which is
around collecting data and one problem
that that I have encountered is even if
you collect the right data often we
don't necessarily know how to include
that in our system right is it is it a
question of a separate accessibility
mode which we've been moving away from
from the last few decades or how do we
think about even if we have this data
and we're able to get it what we can do
with it
the other concern and that I'll point
out is a lot of people with disabilities
and chronic health conditions rely on
this existing infrastructure of
therapists and medical practitioners and
I think we saw a bunch of examples here
that were direct between the
technologists and the end-users and
there's a lot of benefits to that but
there's a conservative we might actually
lose the these expert practitioners who
might not be able to keep up and one
thing I've seen in some of our work is
when we include therapists there are
other subject experts in the problems
they're often extremely conservative
about trying things up typically much
more so than the end users and our
favoring things that are simple and
really understandable I think Melanie
really wants to okay I tend to add on
what Sean said one other thing which is
I think that his point about data is
really good because the the
generalizability of AI systems are sort
of only as good as the data that we
collect and trained on and as a specific
example if you going back to what Jeff
said so you know lately there have been
a bunch of advances with deep learning
in computer vision right and being able
to take photographs and identify the
objects in the photograph but those
systems are trained on high quality
photographs right so those systems for
example even though there's this desire
to make applications or someone who's
visually
here'd could take a picture and then
have the contents of the picture labeled
for them by artificial intelligence
people who are visually impaired take
very low-quality photographs typically
and the vision algorithms are not
trained on the type of low-quality
photographs that people who are visually
impaired take and so until you kind of
broaden your training data set you're
not going to be able to accommodate that
use case again this is a terrific panel
I'm so excited to see this work in
Microsoft's embrace and encouragement of
all this the little surprise and even
going back to your first slide of all of
the different categories that aging is
not part of this agenda it's important
to recognize that the National Institute
of Aging has changed the definition of
what's considered normal aging to be to
include management of chronic diseases
or other types of impairments it's a
really interesting combination of many
of the things that you talked about and
could obviously increase kind of the
scale and impact of what you're doing I
agree and actually that's just an
omission on the slide I think aging is
an example of something that cuts across
all of these different categories of
sensory and motor cognitive and just as
I was mentioning that you know maybe one
in five people have a permanent
disability but there are also temporary
disabilities like breaking limb or
situational impairments aging is another
example of the broad applicability of
this issue because hopefully all of us
will become older and as people age you
begin to acquire different disabilities
and I think overall the aging population
you know especially if you look at the
population curves in places like Japan
and the United States where we have a
large segment of the population that's
aging relative to the younger population
thinking about how AI technologies can
help support for example Aging in Place
and longer duration of quality of life
with respect to your lifespan is a
really important challenge that we
should all care about because it's going
to impact all of us at some point
kind of curious how to think about
integrating these AI technologies into
your research as it evolved so I thought
Walter had this interesting point of if
you inserted the speech recognizer as
another one of the crowd because these
technologies are changing really rapidly
and so unless you're like deep into the
AI you sometimes you might not know so
the difference in quality of speech
recognition from 2011 when you probably
did that work versus today I mean it's
still not perfect still doesn't always
work but it is dramatically better you
know we've done studies where we saw at
least four short text messages three
times faster than people typing and not
making many errors so I'm curious how
you start to think about same with all
those vision systems how do we like
include the systems and regularly update
it to see like how much how would our
algorithms change if the AI technology
you know hit a different threshold and
as they're important thresholds when it
gets beyond something that it changes
the whole architecture how you think
about it it seems like for a lot of us
like we do the problem post paper we
move on the next thing but it's like how
would we think about how these systems
would evolve over time as underlying
technology improves and in fact a lot of
your research is how do we get the
datasets that would help the technology
improve and so the question is are we
getting there yet where we start to see
these systems almost improving as that
happen yeah so I guess as the ones who
maybe plays the architectures a little
bit more on the panel like the idea is
that we want to create workflows for
crowds that actually are more coherent
when it when looked at to the lens with
just intelligent contributors right then
a black box coming from speech
recognition side of things we know what
role it plays in the system as long as
they continues to play that role with
long speech recognition produces text
from an audio input signal then the hope
is that we don't actually have to
reengineer anything it's just a matter
of dropping the latest version of
whatever the state of the art is into
that box and then it becomes interesting
for the more general views
to say I want to be able to have the
system automatically adapt itself right
so that for speech recognition one of
the interesting things that we were
looking at in the community was that we
do have these professionals right we
have people who are trained and have
trained for years and have kind of
worked for special decades doing this
job at a very high level you know high
level they have a mastered a skill we
don't want to just displace everybody
because now we can do with anyone in the
crowd right we actually want to be able
to do I think in response to Anthony's
question I mentioned that we did some on
something on adaptation and try and
actually custom-fit what each
contributor was was able to to provide
there we want to actually be able to say
that if you come in and you're
professional we can get more benefit
from your effort we will pay you kind of
a larger percentage of the entire task
value similarly as speech recognition
gets better it kind of grows into its
place until it simply is the entire
system right now I think creating these
architectures is really difficult so I
think it's an open challenge and to add
to how to generalize that fully we've
seen a lot of different examples right
now in different spaces
let's follow one to that especially
since my colleague Florian messes there
in the back actually share a floor with
a speech recognizer which preach
recognition researcher and a street
record now he does graded it he does
create it both of those things but um
and and I think I think one of the
challenges especially from the
crowdsourcing perspective is that I
think that we do need expertise in these
various domains in order to to do this
well and so in the case of the speech
recognition work that fluorine is
Florian and I as
students have kind of continued you know
it's really hard to figure out a way to
get the crowd to effectively work with
the automatic speech recognition the
speech recognition systems work very
differently you know the best results
come too slowly for our domain which is
very different we're also not targeting
you know typing short messages with text
messages because that works a lot better
than it used to we're targeting this
continuous real-time captioning of a
lengthy lecture on a topic that the
speech recognizer might not even have
the vocabulary to speak but anyway
figuring those things out it I think is
a really interesting challenge but
definitely requires
working with the domain experts and so
so we're doing that with speech
recognition researchers with computer
vision researchers with dialogue system
researchers it does get a little bit
crazy trying to manage all of that but I
think that it's important to do that
I think I mean kind of generalize that I
think it kind of changes the structure a
lot of times of the problem so instead
of going from we've got a data set and
we're trying to get as good as
performance as possible on this data set
which is kind of a common pattern across
a lot of different AI research we're
taking it too we have this interactive
application and we have this we've now
situated it right so we have it in this
lecture and we're assuming this student
is going to come and you know they're
just going to show up and they're pull
out their phone well where does that
speech recognition system that's been
trained on a static data set fall down
and where it falls down is it doesn't
know this out of vocabulary words it's a
jargon for the course for example right
or doesn't know this particular speaker
you know the audio quality is poor and
so how do we change the structure of the
problems that the AI researchers are
working on so that it meets some of
these important kind of situated tasks I
think that's kind of thank you so just I
hate to cut off the conversation but the
folks in back are holding up a sign
telling you to wrap up and I don't want
to stand between you all and lunch but
what I would say is that and I don't
want to stand between our speakers and
lunch either so what I would suggest is
that for those of you who'd like to chat
more with the speakers perhaps you can
come up and then go to lunch together
and sit and continue this discussion
over lunch and of course we'll all be
here throughout the rest of this event
and thank you so much
[Applause]